le 25 juin 2009 michael jackson mourrait
à los angeles une mort brutale qui va
choquer tout les fans un émoi relayée
dans les jt madame j bonjour vous l'avez
compris l'essentiel de ce journal sera
consacré à la mort de michael jackson
l'une des plus grandes stars de
l'histoire de la musique
en quatre jours il y aura trois heures
et huit minutes de reportage consacré à
la star rien que sur les jt du soir de
grandes chaînes généralistes mais les
reportages et les éditions spéciales
commence dès 13 heures le 26 juin
décalage horaire oblige il a fait santé
et danser le monde entier michael
jackson est mort cette nuit à seulement
50 ans sur france 2 et france 3 les
éditions de la mi-journée était presque
exclusivement consacrées au décès de la
star avec des invités en plateau mais
aussi des duplex depuis los angeles
quel est le climat il ya beaucoup de
tristesse j'imagine à los angeles
c'est vrai que j'irais bien au delà de
los angeles que c'est toute l'amérique
en fait qui est sous le choc
en france les fans de l'artiste s'était
donné rendez vous sur le parvis de notre
dame et toutes les chaînes y était
survenu
à parler des millions j'ai même des
milliards c'était le seul ne peut pas
dire c'est dieu mais bon ça on peut pas
dire ça mais franchement c'est michael
jusqu'à la mort à moi le 26 juin à 20
heures
la mort du chanteur faisait encore la
une vous l'avez compris un seul titre ce
soir à la une de votre journal la mort
de michael jackson la star planétaire
s'est éteinte hier de nouveau des
invités prennent place sur les plateaux
c'est un beat qui viennent disparaître
c'est aussi bizarre que ça les jours
suivants michael jackson sera encore
bien présent dans les jt passé le choc
de sa mort et les hommages celle enquête
autour des causes de son décès mais
aussi l'héritage du chanteur qui
intéresseront les médias au total entre
le 26 et le 29 juin
on décompte 92 sujet dans les jt de
début de soirée de tf1 france 2 france 3
canal+ et m6 en comparaison pina baush
figures de la danse contemporaine qui
est décédé trois jours après
a eu droit à quatre sujets sur les mêmes
chaînes
[Musique]